gold silver and diamonds question how
much does delegation play in effective
time management delegation is
outrageously important in effectively
managing your time especially at the
entrepreneur level because you're going
to start doing everything you know like
you're going to have to do everything
but as your business grows and as you
grow on you know you're going to have to
be able to you know trust others to do
certain things to free you up for doing
the things that you're really really
good at um but then also you know
admitting to yourself that there might
be things that other people are better
at than you are you know so like if
you're a if you're an entrepreneur that
has a blog and you're doing all the
graphic design for your blog posts um
you might not be a natural-born graphic
designer that might not be your strong
point so I there's going to come a point
a juncture where you know you're you're
making enough to justify delegating that
task and paying someone who's
professional graphic designer that is
going to take that time away from you so
you're going to have that time back
you're going to be able to allocate it
in other parts of your business but on
top of that they're probably going to do
a better job than you and that's okay
you know so like being able to develop
trust with other people is important in
terms of getting ahead if if if you're
spending a lot of time doing menial
tasks like mowing the lawn for example
and you know there's there's a kid two
houses down who would love to mow your
lawn for twenty bucks a month um be okay
with you know if you can afford it
relinquishing that 20 bucks a month and
you're going to get that time back and
you're going to be able to allocate that
time it's part of the way um so there's
there's there's things with delegation
where it's like um there's the
day-to-day you know the task that
absolutely has to get done and they can
be done by anybody be prepared to
delegate those and then there's the
tasks that you're doing that you
probably shouldn't be doing be prepared
to admit that to yourself and find the
best person for the job and start
developing a relationship and developing
trust with that
to know that they have you know your
business and your interest in line so
that you can pass that off and focus on
other aspects of your business yeah I
love it the order that I like to go in
is eliminate automate delegate so well
chances are there's a lot of things that
you're doing are right in your business
that that just shouldn't be done so
there's no point giving them of somebody
else because it's not high value high
leverage it should be eliminated from
this completely step two is automate
where if you can automate an important
task it's way better to do that than to
give it to somebody else to do right
because you know it'll get done faster
computers don't make mistakes they don't
take vacationers and and chances are
it's a much more menial task you know
don't necessarily give to human being
and then the third is delegate so you
eliminate first automate second delegate
third and I think understanding that to
do something big you have to build
beyond yourself and a lot of
entrepreneurs have a hard time hi hareen
in a session with the first hires and
make mistakes and often feel like man I
can't get the right person not so I'm
just going to do it all myself we
retreat in words but to do something big
to really have an impact you have to be
able to build a team out because you
can't do everything yourself and
understanding again go back to the
understand your point of leverage you
are great at something you want to focus
on that and what you love and then use
people who are better than you like you
said at other skills to help round out
those weaknesses to help you get to
where you want to go so yeah I mean I
agree it's a huge factor in effective
time I in for your business